for our next stop we are traveling over
a th miles with our resident Edge
weapons expert Doug
maraa we're heading to combat ready art
in kalamazo
Michigan once a manufacturing Hub to
automobiles paper and Railway supplies
the area has been transformed into a
thriving art community and the forite
shows specializes in making blades and
props for theater and stage combat now
three of their top Smiths will compete
to represent sent both this shop and me
for their chance becoming a forge and
fire
Champion gentlemen congratulations the
two of you are now moving forward in the
second round of this tournament
gentlemen we want you to build another
iconic weapon from Shakespearean history
we want you to build
this this here is MC Beth's
sword during the 11th century the real
McBeth reigned as the king of the Scots
for only 17 years but his legacy
famously lives on
though based on fiction William
Shakespeare's play features one of the
greatest Duels of all time where McDuff
notoriously decapitates MC Beth in the
final
battle this interpretation of MCB best
sword is a faithful rendition of
Scottish swords from the 11th century
featuring a wide double-edged blade this
sword is deadly enough for cutting and
cleaving anyone and anything in its path
making it an ideal weapon for a
king So blad Smith we've got a unique
situation here because you guys both
work out of this Forge you'll both be
making your swords here at the same time
so good luck we'll see you both back at
our home Forge in 4
days I have a bit of a game plan that
I'm going to try to stick to my goal
today is to try to get my shape pulled
and I'm ready to get going really
getting pretty nervous with a link like
this you know it leaves a lot of room
for
warping I have my blade shaped like I
want so the quench is definitely the
most nerve-wracking thing about about
this process for me I've never heat
treated a blade to this link I could end
up with cracks I could end up with warps
here goes
nothing well I'm glad to get that over
with it's
looking fairly
straight was definitely the most
stressful part of this process in my
opinion all I have left to do is shape
the handle and do some sharpening now
I'm going to start working on my guard
I'm not planning on welding the guard on
so I'm going to use a steel
epoxy I am very proud of what I made at
the end of the day regardless to how it
holds up in the test I'm super stoked on
my final product my plan for today is
just going to try and Forge out as much
as I can just stretching it out so I'm
making the largest blade I've ever made
in my life with this material you can
probably make 10 of what I'm used to
once I get my tip established I'm moving
down blade there's too much material
there to move my hammer I'm going to
give my arms a break and go over to the
trle Hammer trle Hammer is going to help
me move more steel quicker than my arms
can and also thin out my
blade I get my blade pretty much drawn
out I'm liking the progress I'm making I
like the shape so far blade looks like a
sword I'm pretty nervous about this
quench this is the biggest thing I've
ever tried quenching
before
oh it's warped I need to fix this warp
somehow or I will be in
trouble I don't have time to pick them
up so I just stand on it I end up
melting my shoe on it a little bit oh
well they're old so it's not
straight it's it's straighter than it
was though the warp on my MCB sword is
like super noticeable I don't really
have time to fix it today I'm pretty
intent with how my guard looks how it
feels I need to fit a handle pommel and
clean up my blade to finish it I think
this sword will give me a chance at
$220,000 blad Smiths welcome to the
keill
test well your mcbet swords look
dramatic but are they lethal well to
find that out I'm going to take your
weapon deliver some thrust and slashes
on this ballistics dummy Blake your
approach you ready for this I'm
ready
all right bit let's talk about your
sword here first up your Edge is sharp
and took no damage it's a good start to
the Masterpiece your handle construction
is smooth but one thing about your
handle here is that it's actually much
more comfortable to hold it this way as
it is this way but I like how it feels
and how it moves with the movement
overall sir your weapon
look hell yeah all right Jackson are you
ready yep I'm ready let's do
this
who would have thought the old man would
have so much blood on him Jackson let's
talk about your MC Beth sword here first
up before we started your blade already
had two BS you have one at this juncture
and another one up here so almost like
an SB on that but it didn't get any
worse your Edge your Edge is sharp it
was easy to wield and cuts deeply into
the biscus dummy overall your weapon
it will kill thank
you all right blad Smith this is a
dynamic strength test the paint C bash
and the sandbag slice Blake you're up
first you ready for this yes
sir
all right blade let's talk about your
sword here I love the balance you have
on your sword your Edge suffered no
damage cutting into these paint cans and
they slice nicely on the sandbags
overall you're wel happen it is strong
and it will cut thank you all right
Jackson your turn you ready I'm ready
let's do
this
all right Jackson let's talk about your
sword your Edge suffered no damage
cutting into these paint cans and they
sliced nicely on the sandbags Color Me
impressed but your blade earlier had a
little bit of a bend and it did get
worse
there's some movement that happened
during the test um your Edge did not
have any damage though and overall you
have a strong and sharp sword good job
thank you gentleman Doug chose your
Forge combat ready art in cazo Michigan
to represent him in the finals of our on
the road tournament you both turned in
impressive swords but unfortunately only
one of you can move
forward and the BL Smith moving forward
in this competition
is wait
congratulations well Jackson from the
very beginning it was clear that you put
everything you had in this competition
and we want to say thank you for coming
out but unfortunately your time in this
tournament has ended I'm going to have
to ask you to please step off the forth
floor good job man good
job I agree with Doug's assessment of my
sword it was very difficult but I did
make it this far and I'm proud of that
my sword came in with some warps and
during the testing it moved which is not
good I'm going home but I'm going to
keep making blade and do
blacksmithing well Blake congratulations
that means you are moving forward in the
final leg of this tournament still in
the fight for $20,000 for yourself and
an extra 10 that could potentially go to
John come on up here and Shake our hands
man I appreciate it I'm super stoked I'm
very pleased with what I created but I'm
also really curious what these next
rounds are going to have for us it's
pretty surreal proud to be the
representative of combat ready art at
the final so let's see what we
do